This shouldn't surprise you at this point,
but Heather, Josh and the other stars of
the "Blair Witch" films didn't really die. Some
launched careers in Hollywood, while others have
turned their back on the business. Here's what
happened to the cast of the "Blair Witch" movies.
She's the most recognizable face of
the "Blair Witch" franchise -- and
that's not necessarily a good thing. As Heather
Donahue sadly admitted to The Guardian in 2016,
"My name and face are for ever going to
be someone else’s intellectual property."
This is what happened when she shot
to stardom playing "herself" as the
film's lead Blair Witch believer
and documentarian investigator.
While she said that making the film was a
"joy," immediate success afterwards was elusive,
especially as the marketing team at Artisan
Entertainment wanted her to act as though she
were really dead. For a long time her IMDb profile
listed her as deceased at age 24. This confusion
about her mortality status didn't help land her
many subsequent roles, but she did manage to
carve out parts in a dozen or so movies later,
before calling it quits on Hollywood in 2007.
Her next move was to the Sierra Nevada foothills,
where she became a grower of medical marijuana.
Donahue's high times became the basis for her
green memoir, "Growgirl," which was published in
2012. She then co-created and tried to shop around
a pot comedy pilot called "The High Country."
These days, Donahue is currently focused on
developing a line of herbal skin-care products,
and inspiring and teaching others to
share their own stories through writing.
Josh Leonard told The Guardian back in 2018,
"I was up for any kind of adventure back then,
so said yes when [directors Daniel Myrick and
Eduardo Sánchez] asked me to play the cameraman."
Leonard also experienced troubles being
listed as deceased on IMDb by the Artisan
marketing department, to the point that his
parents started getting condolence calls in
response to the fake news. His career came very
much alive after the film, when he decided to
earnestly pursue the craft of acting and stop,
quote, "being the guy from 'Blair Witch.'"
A year later he appeared opposite Robert De
Niro and Cuba Gooding Jr. in "Men of Honor,"
followed by a steady diet of independent films,
network TV shows, and video game voice overs.
Inspired by his work in Lynn Shelton's
improvised 2009 mumblecore film "Humpday,"
he branched out as a director,
with 2011's "The Lie," and later
with 2018's "Dark Was The Night,"
and 2020's "Fully Realized Humans."
Leonard continues to be a working actor
in projects like Steven Soderbergh's 2018
iPhone horror flick "Unsane" and TV series
including "Bates Motel" and "Togetherness."
He has been married to fellow
actor Allison Pill since 2015.
Michael Williams is a very common name, but the
Bronx born sometimes-actor knows you know him
better as "Mike" aka "The map guy" aka "The guy
in the corner" from "The Blair Witch Project."
He extended his resume by guesting on a few TV
shows like "Law & Order" and "FBI," as well as
reuniting with director Eduardo Sánchez for his
2006 horror film "Altered." Williams enlisted
Sánchez and his "Witch" co-star Joshua Leonard
for the 2013 webseries "Four Corners of Fear."
While he does have a few new projects on the
horizon, Williams has moved away from having a
full time career as an actor. He currently works
as a school counselor, is an adjunct faculty
member at the Jacob Burns Media Arts Lab, and runs
the MCW Acting Studio alongside his wife Toni.
Williams is currently writing
a book about his debut film,
with the working title "Escaping
the Most Famous Corner in Hollywood:
How I Survived the Blair Witch." In his free
time, he enjoys fishing in the great outdoors.
Ed Swanson isn't much of a fisherman,
nor an actor, but he played up both
in "The Blair Witch Project," as our trio
of filmmakers headed deep into the woods.
Swanson was on director Eduardo Sánchez's softball
team and was asked to play a part in the movie.
Besides that performance, Swanson hasn't
acted outside of community and church theater.
He was in the Marine Corps, and got out right
before the Gulf War. This brought him to Maryland
where the film was shot, and he still resides
there to this day. Now in his fifties,
he's carved out a niche for himself
as an artisan who creates clocks.
As for his fishing buddy with the hat in the film,
Bob Griffin? He had never met him before the film,
nor saw him after. According to Swanson,
his scene partner has since passed away.
Susie Gooch was in the right place at the
right time when she and her young daughter
Ingrid were interviewed for what they thought
was an actual student film. They didn't think
much about their ad-libbed lines until a friend
two years later said they'd seen them in a movie
called "The Blair Witch Project," where Susie
was listed in the credits as "Jackie Hallex."
The non-acting, natural ladies relish their
roles in the film, and have happily appeared
at screenings and filming location tours in the
years since. Susie has been a teacher for over
34 years and currently works as a tutor
in Maryland. Ingrid graduated from Hood
College with a Master's of Science in Clinical
Mental Health Counseling, is currently the Lead
Clinician at an Outpatient Recovery Centers, is
a big Korn fan, and is engaged to be married.
Attempting to capitalize on the hoopla behind
"The Blair Witch Project," a quasi-sequel,
"Book of Shadows: Blair Witch
2," hit theaters a year later,
launching a filming locations "tour"
of the first film within this film,
led by Jeffery Patterson. Patterson was
played by Jeffrey Donovan, who knew the
risks of alienating fans of the original
by outright saying it was pure fiction.
Fans and critics didn't care for this approach,
but it had little effect on Donovan's career.
His acting visibility started to pick up steam
when he appeared in the 2005 Will Smith vehicle
"Hitch," and two years later he landed a
stint on TV's "Crossing Jordan." Leading
man status was achieved when he got noticed as
Michael Westen in USA Network's "Burn Notice."
In between he played Robert F. Kennedy in Clint
Eastwood's "J. Edgar," and later his brother
John F. in Rob Reiner's "LBJ." Other works of
note include Season 2 of "Fargo," playing opposite
Angelina Jolie in Eastwood's "Changeling," and
in "Lucy in the Sky" alongside Natalie Portman.
When Kim Director heard about a "Blair
Witch" sequel she was skeptical at first,
but "hit the floor" when she found out
she was going to be directed by acclaimed
"Paradise Lost" documentarian Joe Berlinger. She
described her psychic Kim Diamond character in
"Book of Shadows" as a "very intuitive,
slightly depressed, acidic goth girl."
Director feels the follow-up didn't
do well because of poor marketing,
and that it ultimately "had a lot
that it had to fight against."
"I thought the movie was cool."
Despite its failure, "Book of Shadows" was
a breakout role for Director — actually her
forth one, after securing small parts in the
Spike Lee films "He Got Game," "Summer of Sam"
and "Bamboozled." She reunited with Lee in
2004 for "She Hate Me," 2006's "Inside Man,"
and the Netflix series version of "She's Gotta
Have it." Outside of her Lee collaborations,
she has kept busy with other films, as well
as appearances in notable shows like "Sex
and the City," "Law & Order," "Orange is the
New Black," "The Good Wife," and "Gotham."
One of her larger, more memorable recent roles
was as the sex worker Shay on HBO's "The Deuce."
2016's "Blair Witch" was more of a true
sequel to the original than "Book of Shadows."
It finds Heather's younger brother
James heading into those same,
scary woods to try and find his
sister. McCune told Digital Trends,
"There was a lot of pressure to live
up to the standards of the first one."
The film literally gave him nightmares,
and in 2016 he told USA Today,
"I had dreams of being chased by a creature down
an alleyway on a regular basis. I'd
have dreams of being ripped apart."
McCune is no stranger to nightmares,
having appeared in 11 episodes of "The
Walking Dead" as farmhand Jimmy. He has
also made appearances on series such as
"Shameless," "Homeland," and "How to Get Away
with Murder." In films, he's appeared opposite
the Rock in "Snitch," and had a role in Mary
Harron's tragic Lifetime movie "Anna Nicole"
Recently, he has also added the roles of
producer and assistant director to his profile,
having worked on the web series "Sugar
Pine 7," and the short film "Taipei Jesus."
Lisa Arlington wanted to make a
documentary called "The Absence
of Closure," including the story of Heather
Donahue's brother and her boyfriend James,
and even "launched" a Kickstarter to help
her make it a reality. In actual reality,
Lisa Arlington was played by Callie Hernandez,
who had a "weirdly fun" time working on the third
"Witch" film's memorable dirty tunnel scene.
In an interview with /Film, she recalled having
a better time handling the close quarters
than the claustrophobic "camera guy" did.
Hernandez's acting career didn't start
until her early 20s, but when it did,
it started with a bang, landing a role that was
later cut in Terrence Malick's "Song to Song."
That was followed by a trio of
parts in Robert Rodriguez projects,
including "Machete Kills". While shooting "Blair
Witch" in Vancouver, she made a singing tape
that led to her playing one of Emma Stone's
roommates in "La La Land." Her credits also
include Ridley Scott's "Alien: Covenant,"
TV's "Graves" and "Under the Silver Lake."
Next on her dance card is joining Jennifer
Lopez and Josh Duhamel for "Shotgun Wedding."
Peter is James' skeptical, childhood
friend in the third "Blair Witch" film,
and is played by Tuscaloosa native Brandon
Scott. Scott told his hometown newspaper that
"[2016's "Blair Witch"] is more of an homage
to the first one, but it takes the story to
the nth degree, even though it leaves a
lot of Easter eggs, and open questions.”
A graduate of New York University's
Tisch School of the Arts in 2004,
Scott has racked up north of 70 credits since
leaving school. His voice was heard in Disney's
"Wreck-It Ralph" and "The Boss Baby" TV series,
and he's been seen in everything from Showtime's
"Guerilla" to "This is Us" to "Dead to Me" and
"Goliath." In a "Blair Witch" alumni pairing,
Scott played "Lucky" in Joshua Leonard's
2018 directed feature "Dark Was the Night."
Corbin Reid was "definitely scared" when reading
the script for "Blair Witch," for which she was
cast as Ashley. The poor girl gets a nasty
infection on her foot during the journey,
which is one of the last things
you'd want in the deep dark woods.
In real life, Reid was able to escape the forest
and nab 13 episode stints on both "How to Get Away
with Murder" and "Valor." In 2019, she wrote,
directed and executive produced the short film
"Blind Sight," and she is currently making waves
starring on the Starz series "Run The World."
The Minnesotan is an avid long-distance runner,
a lover of puppies, and interior design.
Her dream role is to play Whitney Houston.
In the third "Blair Witch" film, locals Lane
and Talia are conspiracy theorists who found
lost footage of Heather Donahue taped to
a tree in the woods. Their find sets the
plot in motion, with the two acting
as guides for James and his friends.
Valorie Curry, who played Talia, never saw the
original when she was younger, telling Vogue,
"I was terrified of E.T. as a small
child! I had a low threshold for fear."
Curry's early acting career began with 6 episodes
of "Veronica Mars," but she took a break soon
after to see if another vocation would stick ...
and it didn't. She returned to the craft in 2011
with parts on "CSI: NY," "Psych," "The Twilight
Saga: Breaking Dawn — Part 2," and even appearing
in blink-182's music video for their song
"After Midnight." Her residency on the show "The
Following" not only earned her a steady paycheck,
but it was also where she met her future husband,
actor Sam Underwood. The two have since acted
together in a pair of short films, at the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival, and even performed
music together live. Other notable works include
playing Kara in the video game "Detroit: Become
Human," and appearing in "The Tick" TV series.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.